well the global market turbulence over
the past week has been due to
nervousness sister daily slumps in
China's market share prices have dropped
twenty five percent since last week a
word join now by child Deng from The
Wall Street Journal he's in Hong Kong
thanks for joining us on a sky wardens
can you just tell us what happened on
the Asian markets yesterday well
yesterday markets in Asia rebounded
pretty strongly starts in Shanghai were
actually up by five percent the highest
in more than a month this is after a
huge sell-off took place in recent days
because of anxiety about China's
economic slowdown and that had pushed
down everything from global stocks to
commodities two currencies but
increasingly some investors think that
the self is overdone and that's why you
see more people coming into the market
to buy and that shaping up the rebound
and child what exactly the mark is
saying this morning then um this morning
they're continuing to gain after US
stocks closed higher last night so last
night we had data showing that the US
economy grew by three-point-seven
percent in the second quarter and that
was well ahead of investors expectations
that's good news at a time when
investors are worrying about how China
slowdown is going to affect global
growth so any good news out of the u.s.
is good news for the markets and we see
that if angel today stocks i continue to
rebound as our currencies and in
commodities to oil prices soared last
night by ten percent and that was their
biggest percentage gain in six years now
there will inevitably be concerns that
the downward trend may well a Carol may
well continue to occur what's the
reality of that happening now of course
there's still concerns about what the
u.s. rate hike later this year will do
to markets investors think that that
will introduce more wild swings to come
a stronger US economy actually makes a
stronger argument for the US Federal
Reserve to hike rates sooner rather than
later but after all this market turmoil
investors are thinking that the Fed will
hold back a little bit
on its timeline for the right height so
I mean as we're heading to the close the
week here in Asia markets have been hurt
pretty badly the shanghai composite
index is down about eleven percent this
week so far but at least today at friday
you see volatility has eased a bit and
that investors are are taking solace in
this better US economic data k child
gain from the air Wall Street Journal
thanks for joining us on a sky warden
ease